ultimately Christy was right that it's
about Trump more than anything else uh
and it is interesting to watch the
fighting like it's not I think V is
performing well they you know there have
been interesting moments but ultimately
it the question remains how will anyone
stand up if they were to debate Trump
they won't I it shows the two legitimate
candidates is DeSantis and ramaswami and
the other two are like warhawks that are
just kind of on the trail big money yeah
100% that's like that's absolutely it
and hly like you I was saying earlier is
like on that stage on that stage like
Vic's the guy he's the guy absolutely
for for like normal he has the Charisma
I mean I think there are questions about
his policies in some respects but I
think he always has been the most
charismatic person in in all of these
debate performances again he does have
the occasional thing you know he said
something like I have a longer future
than Donald Trump he has he has sparred
with Donald Trump very indirectly and
again I wonder what that would look like
if they were up against each other